through the city like I'm on to get it
through the city
like and now
Brandon six
boy
sh yeah Monday November 20th 9:00 a.m.
on the dot kids what is popping what's
cracking how are you guys getting ready
for Thanksgiving what's everybody doing
yeah I can't hear you that's cool turkey
dry turkey is usually the norm little
dyed turkey I'm a big stuffing guy
little stuffing a little cranberry sauce
some
gravy it's uh one of the downsides being
married to Mexican they like to uh kind
of take over this
holiday and uh I had to I have to put my
foot down Cas I to put my foot down and
say we got to whiten up around here
because it was too too we got American
up around here well you know make it up
around here just because they'll have
soap soapa the pzo it's just I can't
have soup on a holiday soup soup's not a
meal no dude as a grown man we can't do
it so me and my father-in-law and he
could not get any wher we're in charge
of making this thing a little more
American so I get that dry turkey for
the kids I get the stuffing the
cranberry and they'll they'll it's kind
of a two course meal there Mexican than
American and I force them to watch bad
football it's always the although Lions
since I've been alive have been
traditionally Tera but they're good this
year so won't be terrible football and
Dallas is on two Dallas is always on
Li's on so not terrible so I force him
to watch that but that's it man what you
got are you staying in town I'm going to
San Diego going to ks chin you know
Orange County one my parents your
parents and do you guys do a traditional
you always have every year I always
forget so it's it's a mix of it's a mix
of American and Korean oh yeah so we'll
have kimchi turkey duck no duck no duck
turduckens no dude I would love a
turducken turducken is turkey chicken
and duck I would love that inside of a
duck what's it inside of the duck I
think the turkeyy is a big part than a
duck and then a chicken or or chicken
then duck I don't know disgusting it
sounds amazing to me disgusting whatever
dude yeah whatever man the holiday
uh can kind of mess things up especially
in La like there's no traffic today the
the gyms are empty I guess people are in
vacation where do they go during
Thanksgiving people go on vacation for
Thanksgiving I guess because they have
some days off yeah I mean La in general
just shuts down from like Thanksgiving
to New Year oh yeah I mean La especially
as far as entertainment side literally
the agents all the big agents Hollywood
is off from Thanksgiving to mid January
damn never heard anything of like it the
only people have easier uh vacation
schedules are teachers shout out to
teachers you guys should be paid more
but also you have Summers spring break
winter break fall break come on what are
we doing here but agents man I mean they
get their 10% no matter what dude so
they get all the time off yeah la shuts
down during holidays dude it's weird
trying to get this car stuff together
everyone's on break man I got a problem
with the lightning everybody's on break
it's driving me nuts
it still runs it's just like driving a
Mini Cooper it's not uh it's not how
it's supposed to be so I go to wait till
the
28th to get the PCU checked out because
I can't do it myself it seems
complicated seems weird probably tune it
myself when it comes to that weird stuff
I should leave it to the professionals
otherwise you going to blow that thing
computer stuff especially yeah with the
tuning on all that stuff I'm like H I
was looking I was reading online shout
out to I think it's lightning modders
the forums fantastic on there I was I've
been reading that I was up at 4:00 a.m.
reading it for about two hours and the
more I go down that rabbit hole I'm like
probably little professional do this now
did I paint the grill yesterday black
yeah I can handle the Cosmetics when it
comes to tuning let's leave it to the
pros I'm gonna blow that thing up I just
get anxiety because I've always tuned my
cars any car you've ever seen me in I've
always tune these things when I say me I
pay somebody to do it usually but I've
never left the car normal in my entire
never never car I've ever had have I
left it normal I it just doesn't make
sense to me so I've always tuned cars
and then now A buddy of mine Hector's
like man you should post this stuff the
car content I'm like all right he was
right and there's I met so many great
people through doing that the problem is
when you decide to take a passion into
content or I guess work is there's time
then then it you got to create content
so then you're on a time schedule
instead when people mod their cars
there's no there's no countdown there's
you don't have to put out content so it
could be a year two years there's no
rush the anxiety I have to create
content through this lightning and TRX
is insane for you guys it keeps me up at
night I got PRS I got PRS but uh yeah it
changes the game a little bit I like the
pressure and all that you know creating
the content to make sure because you
can't go drop dope you know Toontown
episode in November and then take off to
March until you come up with something
so it's it's it's some of this time
crunch when for Content when you guys
see something like that first episode of
toown took months all the all that stuff
takes months so you see it in 12 minutes
so it's like the next episode you got
it's kind of you know we'll figure it
out though we'll figure it out but it's
like condensing everything that most
people do in three maybe three years and
then you're months months you're waiting
on this company or this part this tune
or just
like and then you know it just takes a
like the cars is different than anything
else like especially when you're working
with you know tuning and stuff like that
it
just they just don't move fast you know
like yeah we're in man you're like cool
say less two weeks ago by hey man just
falling up got a got an abso truck grade
here let me know he's like no doubt
we'll get right back y right two months
hey bro just so we got to create this
content and he's like oh right you're
not just doing it to do it so most times
again people take a few years to get the
stuff done you trying to condense it
down a month two months three months
yeah and if there's an issue like with
the lightning all right bud it's fun I
love it I'm obsessed with consumed with
it the frustration comes I'm not I'm not
a Gearhead to the point where I can't
change out the headers I can't you know
certain the wiring stuff like I can't do
that where if it was up to me your boy
would be covered in grease if I could do
all of it oh that bad boy would be done
you just you can't it's just not you
gotta leave it to Pros like there's guys
who have worked on like there's one guy
in that lightning moders who's he's
owned 10 Lightnings he's tuned all of
them himself so he knows the ins and
outs of it do this don't do that like
yeah that's the guy you need to listen
to you don't want to make a mistake on
your own ride and blow it up then you
have the aspirations I get a thousand
horsepower to the rear wheels okay bud
well what's that include you're talking
about rods and
the oh my God all this stuff that goes
into that and it's like is that the best
thing for if you want to drive that
every day you can't do a th000 horse
rear wheel horsepower it's just
unrealistic sounds nice but the amount
that goes into just building that engine
so it doesn't blow up and so you can
drive it for a daily that's not
realistic it's just not 600 700 rear
wheel horsepower that's realistic when
you say 1,000 re wheel that's come on
bud yeah this isn't Vin Diesel we're not
stealing Parts you know I'm not jumping
off Bridges you know I don't have a Vin
Diesel spoon God I wish you were a Vin
Diesel you know i' would be dope chin if
you could do all the tuning I wish I
could you would hate me I would harass
you all the we'd be hanging out all the
time all like hey dude I can't work on a
Sunday at 11: p a. I'm like yes you can
I know and I'll just be hanging out
drinking beers watching you do work dude
shops are so crazy I remember us doing
it all of our friends we were in a car
club so it would take literally 6 months
or or even longer for just to do like
body work engine work it just takes
forever but I'm sure you're on the top
of the list but even though you're
you're on top of the list it's going to
take time take time yeah and I'm so
impatient yeah the worst you've ever
seen yeah but that's the way it goes uh
all right as far as fight news goes it's
it's the it's a slow time right now um
kind of slow so this is what in the biz
we call the off seon for UFC uh fight
fans this would be the offseason you got
a banger happen at the end of uh
December we will have a fight campaign
for that we get some great guests lined
up but uh as far as you know just we
we've been on a bender here where you've
had great content great fights one after
the other UFC really cranks out and then
like the entertainment business they
shut it down you have some fight nights
those Apex centers basy and Dana Dana's
backyard he doesn't show up in his
pajamas the crowd's not really there
those are a bit of a bummer they don't
really count where I come from but uh
they still count on these professional
fighters records so they're knocking out
a few of these fight nights until they
get to December 16th they're just edging
you to December 16th and Then star in
January then January then we're in
fullblown season you're going January
one you got freaking Ali Vera 2 and then
uh you got vovi toir area and then
January 13th you got a a freaking
ridiculous fight I think honestly the
website's messed up here cuz uh oh it
says 299 January 1 298 January 1 yeah so
the first fight card it should go
January February March so the first
fight card I remember reading this it
was anle versus Walker in 2024 so that's
the that should be the first fire c yeah
not January 1 that's weird the UFC
website sometimes is not great dude so
your next big one is January
20th that'd be UFC 297 cuz 298 in
February and then 299s in March so you
can get uh anive and Walker 2 January
13th that's to kickoff the season and
then you have theit first major
pay-per-view January 20th in Toronto
that's UFC 297 you have UFC 298 in
February UFC 299 in um March and then
April's UFC 300
right yes let's see
Yeah March 9th should be that UFC 299
and then
300 they have an idea when it's gonna we
know they're saying April 6 like most
likely April 6 April or yeah I got a
little uh
conspiracy I think because UFC 3 if you
look at the lay of the land most of the
big dogs are taken before UFC 300 so UFC
300 I think you get K MC
Chandler and then I also think and I
have no uh inside sources I didn't
Source check any any anything with this
but if it's just what appears what I
think this could line up I think UFC 300
you're going to get Connor Chandler and
you're gonna get GSP Diaz Nick Diaz
what okay oh that one got you guys huh
that one woke you up huh and here's my
only assumption with that if you noticed
lately gsp's posted a hell of a lot more
he's very he's way more when guys retire
they're usually not that active on
social media they're sure not posting
like training any this you look at gsp's
social media he's posting way more
content he's in phenomenal shape he's
supposed to Grapple on December 15th
they pulled him from that card he's just
commentating on it now right yeah so
he's in shape I think they're pulling
him and I think he's staying in shape to
come out UFC
300 I have no reason to think this no
reason besides just adding up the the
Clues here the social media posts yeah
very active in phenomenal shape was
getting ready to compete in a Jiu-Jitsu
match they pull him from it he's just
commentating they probably went let's
not blow your load on a grappling match
they said he was I think he was supposed
to be injured or or the other guy was
injured I don't know that's what they
said oh and they couldn't find any other
jiujitsu practitioner in the world I'm
not buying it so then in that case if
it's Conor Chandler and GSP Diaz is the
main and co-main of non-title fights
it's a good point yeah because you look
at all the big title fights they're it's
all taken who else they can to put on
there because you have three like 200
UFC 100 UFC 200 UFC
300 100 200 Big Boys man you look at
those cards UFC 100 was a banger man
yeah think about UFC 100 was Brock
Lesnar Frank Mayer uh ridiculous fight
GSP Thiago Alves Dan Henderson Michael
bisbing John Fitch Paulo theago aiyama
Alan Belcher Mark Coleman Stephan Bonner
Jon Jones Jake O'Brien Jim Miller M
Danzig so crazy to see JN on the prelims
too that is crazy right yeah so I got
out the that Friday was the day before
UFC uh 100 and I got out of the ultimate
fighter house on that Friday because I
went to gsp's hotel room uh before wayin
before he weighed in how'd that go he
was nervous as hell yeah and I barely
knew him he's like Brendan I don't know
what to do I'm like I just got out of
Ultimate Fighter house man I don't think
you want any advice from me dude but uh
that was what yeah cuz they had the big
Expo too at that thing it was
crazy but you look at UFC 100 bangers
obviously times are different now
they're not going to load it that much
look at UFC
200 Tate
Nunes so you got Amanda Nunes Misha Tate
Brock Lesnar again Mark hunt DC Anderson
Silva remember that was supposed to be
somebody else short notice Jose Al
Frankie Edgar Kane Travis Brown Pena Kat
Zeno on the undercard Kevin gastam
Johnny Hendricks TJ Dillashaw aans Sage
northcut who was a big deal at the time
Joe Lo luoan Diego Sanchez Gard
mousasi Jim Miller gy stack dude UFC 200
was more stacked than 100 now why was
UFC 200 more stacked than 100 because
this when they're trying to get Acquired
and get uh evaluated and bought out so
they stacked this on purpose remember
that's where Mark
Hunt's lawsuit with Brock Lesnar in the
UFC came about with all this they
brought Brock Lesnar in so this was and
they had that horrible yellow mat was
supposed to be gold but someone messed
up on the paint color it was weird yeah
it was hurt your eyes but uh so UFC 200
stacked 100 stacked you don't think
they're going to stack 300 some big
names they're dorly known for pulling
these Legends out during the 100s 200s
why would they do it for 300 also pfl
ACU uh acquired Bellator this
morning so what hold on go back to this
I'll get back to belor acquired okay
acquired by pfl so location rumors go
[Music]
down here's the rumors part you'll see
300 rumors John Jones will keep them out
yep uh Jones yep Jones can't
um Islam rematch of Charles Olivera that
could happen Pi had an easy night in the
office he could do
PI he wouldn't he wouldn't fight uh
homeboy Touch of
sleep Connor will probably be on
there keep going
that's so they know as much as I do
exactly but there's gonna be some big
names that's why I the GSP thing makes
sense to me if they can get him out of
retirement but clearly he wants to
compete he's posted he's more active on
social media Nate Diaz is down to
fight could happen you got Connor on
there Chandler who knows could Alex
Pierre could make it happen Mev Charles
ol could happen on there
doore wants to
fight they're gonna have to stack it
though and again my point of them
stacking UFC 300 they're going to stack
it no matter what they'll figure it out
but I think there's even more incentive
to stack it because pfl acquiring
Bellator happened this
morning
um and their big thing on this is
because we have Bellator and also pfl
now says our fighter roster equal to the
UFC both 30% top 25 World ranked
Fighters so this pitch never really
works whenever an organization Compares
himself to UFC it it it never works out
so even though statistically they can
match you know 3% of the top 25 World
ranked fighters in the overall rankings
no matter what organization they're in
you don't have the top the 30 the top 25
30% is should say of stars you're top 3%
nobody gives a flying [__] about just be
completely
transparent do I watch them yes but I'm
a weirdo and hardcore and most like
people watching this you watch it but as
far as the casuals they can't name your
top two in any weight class that's the
issue that's why Bellator failed
Bellator failed because they could never
get their own Stars they always got
outdated older
guys who were built in the UFC and came
over to Bellator when they were way past
their Prime and that's how they got
recognition you can't build a business
model off that you can't make money
doing that you have to build your own
stars and pfl's kind of heading that
direction you know but think about it
they they have Anthony Pettis right they
they did that they've had other guys
they do have Jake Paul which is a little
different they have Francis but where
did Francis you know get his notoriety
at UFC so these leagues like notice one
Championship one of the reasons they
stick out they build all their own
roster they don't have older UFC
fighters or current UFC fighters that
have an issue with data and then come
over they build their own roster outside
of just MMA they have striking they have
Jiu-Jitsu so it's they're completely in
a different Lane and they're massive but
when it comes to the US this is where I
disagree with the MMA experts I don't
refer to myself as an expert in any
facet but the journalists out there that
go competition's good for the UFC it's
it's a shame that Bellator is going
under I disagree I don't think there's
enough eyeballs for multiple
organizations in America alone
internationally yes but as far as
America goes how have other football
leagues done awful how have other
basketball leagues done awful why aren't
there more baseball leagues because
there's not enough five balls on the MLB
why would someone Branch off do their
own thing so when it comes to the US I'm
not talking about internationally but it
comes to the US there's
only enough attention span for one major
organization it's the UFC a because they
have all the stars they have all the
money they have all the backing they
have the funds and the marketing to make
Superstars there's not enough resources
there's not enough eyeballs for other
organizations in America there's just
not if there were if there were if there
was that much capacity to do do that
you'd have other football leagues
football's way bigger than MMA in
America basketball's way bigger than MMA
in America so you you would have other
organizations there's a reason why you
don't there's a One-Stop shop when
people refer to MMA they say UFC when
they refer to to tissue paper they refer
to Kleenex when they refer to soda they
refer to as Coke UFC is MMA in
America I don't think there will ever be
any
competition there could be some fun ones
and we'll watch them in here
because we create the content we're
we're weirdos we watch everything but
there's just not enough resources for
another League to to excel it UFC has it
on lock nobody will ever come close
there's no other Dana whites there's no
other roster Like It in America it's
just not freaking happening so if you
want to get in the game and be second
best by all means do
it by all means do it and this this bfl
thing and belor thing I think it's good
but they're going to leave it separate
the belor guys from what I understand
can still join the pfl tournament style
where they're up for a million dollars
but they're still going to leave it
separate and they're going to do a mega
fight of Bellator Champs and pfl Champs
again the issue is it doesn't matter do
we like it here yes but it doesn't
matter if you have one unrecognizable
Champion with whatever League it is
fighting another champion that we never
heard of they fight okay you're in the
same rankings
you're getting the same
ratings it doesn't
matter you can get more competitive
fights that's dope but as far as stars
there's a reason why this took so long
for Bellator to get bought out what are
you buying you're buying a sinking ship
let's be
honest name 10 Bellator Fighters
Goen you know what I'm saying yeah I can
I can name 10 that they've had in the
past because they're because they their
associations with pride or with strike
force with UFC as far as belor built and
grown you know it's
tough it's tough so if you want to be
second best but you have at it it's just
not happening it's just not happening
and then reason why they're not just
folding Bellator into pfl is you have
two separate TV deals so there's more
income for the owners so the pfl has
ESPN in the back end of the Saudis now
that they've acquired Bellator it's
going to be separate things so you're
double dipping you getting two different
TV deals even though even if it's all
under ESPN it's still two separate deals
so they're double dipping getting both
the benefits soad of just folding into
one UFC did it WC did with strike first
for a little bit but they're double
dipping then they F until they they
drain that thing and then they fold into
one so we see what happens I just don't
even them acquiring bellator's roster
it's not like they're acquiring this
insane roster yeah there's a lot of
talent but as far as stars go I don't
know but with the Saudi money in the
backing and you got Jake Paul and
Francis over there they could make some
waves for sure but as far as trumping
UFC not happening the only thing that
could trip the UFC up the only thing is
this lawsuit if you're not paying
attention to it you should you you're
going to get into the weeds there you
should pay attention to it because the
way these lawsuits work is usually an
organization as big as the UFC worth
billions and billions of dollars
if they get sued they usually settle
here here's a mill here's a bill get out
of here and it goes away the difference
in this is is now this is going to court
and this what they've been fighting for
it gets Court they have to you know
relinquish all their uh accounting stuff
like that which we haven't been privy
to the issue is the people behind this
Kung Lee John Fitch kek all these all
these dudes and the lawyers if they
settle there was no reason for this if
they settle it doesn't change the game
for the better so to my understanding
they're not going to settle the UFC
would be lucky to settle at A3 billion
lawsuit three
bill now if this goes to court which it
is if this goes to court which it's
going to and the UFC loses they're going
to around5
billion which I don't care who you work
for how much money you have five billion
would really really hurt the
UFC okay I'm just looking huge blow I'm
just looking at this right now I just
typed in the plaintiffs it says kungle
Nate Cory John Fitch brenon ver Javier
Vasquez and Kyle kingsb I don't think uh
John uh Josh kosek is in it I'm not sure
though I'd be surprised if he's not but
just yeah I'm just this a quick Google
but yeah so you got uh Vasquez Cal
kingsberry kungle Nate
Curry John
Fitch that that one's
interesting
because again usually a company of UFC's
magnitude they can just pay them off and
go away and it's over you sign the Nas
and all that stuff and it's over but
when you're dealing with fighters who
aren't just going to take the money and
run because they want to change the game
UFC's in some trouble yeah and I don't
want to see UFC get hurt I don't I don't
want to see him go down I absolutely
don't want to see that it would be nice
if there's some changes in Fighters pay
and this is the only way to do exactly
yes unfortunately way to do it and he
gotten to the point where you're looking
at a five five billion plus payout if
they win good chance they win they got
some dogs on their team they got some
dog I mean UFC's have the best lawyers
in the business but so do these boys so
so you got two Titanics facing each
other but that's the one thing that
could hurt the UFC where pfl with their
Saudi backing money could kind of make
some ground here depend what the the
court forces UFC to do because they have
a
monopoly
yeah and that judge that reopened it and
said they wanted more I guess more
Discovery to open up more of the files
yeah so that's the the more they have to
do Discovery the worse it is for the
UFC my my only question is so how's UFC
different than I I know how they're
different in aspects of the NFL are
employees the players are employees
they're not subcontracted UFC says
they're not employees they're
subcontracted so the you know the Union
all that stuff all right
cool I'm I'm just curious how the NFL is
not
Monopoly the NBA is not Monopoly there's
somebody way smart who can explain this
who's pulling their hair out right now
like this is why I get it I'm just I
it's just a simple question how can the
NFL and NBA and MLB do
it and the UFC can't how are they
different than that now is it just
because they're Fighters are labeled as
sub subcontracted so they have to share
as much revenue and health benefits and
stuff like that and 401ks and retirement
compensation I assume that's how the UFC
finagles their way around it saying
they're subcontract we don't have to
give them that much money where the NFL
can't do that NBA can't do that even
though they're
monopolies yeah nobody knows do they
just a bunch of dumb asses yeah we're
dumb but I mean that makes sense that
every other big league has a player's
Union they collectively bargain
employees yeah because they're in it
together the UFC is not mhm it's the UFC
or bus so the UFC is basically
subcontracted whatever they can benefit
from them as being contractors and then
whatever they can benefit them as being
actual employees they're trying to do
the employee thing but they're
contractors that's why there's like yeah
discrepancy yeah so certain time like
you have to you have to wear this Venom
outfit okay but we're subcontracting the
likeness stuff was also crazy and we
also own your name and likeness okay but
we're subc contracted because you're
treating us like employees but you're
paying us like we're sub
contracted so I I assume these lawyers
are way smarter you'll be surprised man
way smarter than me that's their
argument yeah they're like they're
treating them like employees but paying
them like their subcontract and they
have no benefits they have no leverage
here and then they control the entire
market so they got to be
employees yeah we'll see what happens
it' be cool if they set on okay they're
employees we're give them benefits but
we won't pay $5
billion that's probably best case
scenario where it changes the game
forever their employees they get their
benefits and they get compensation they
have to pay like the NFL or NBA of 50%
or 47% whatever they come to agreement
to but they don't have to pay that lump
sum fine of five plus billion dollars
because that's going to make him go
belly up and then we don't have a
job he'd be tough yeah oh there's if
this show is based on pfl Bellator why
do you think Showtime went belly
up I told him you can't have a business
off Bellator is my number one
disagreement with Showtime I can't do a
show covering Bellator why nobody Tunes
in oh we disagree we just got to build
it n telling you can't do
it they would force right they' forc me
to cover Bel and that was my contract
that you know they had investment bellor
so remember you guys would get make sure
Brennon covers Bellator this and
Bellator I'm like there's nothing there
man nobody cares look at look at the
proofs on the pudding talk about UFC you
get this talk about Bor you get this
it's here yet
clear again they had investment into
Bellator and I get it Scott coker's
great absolutely love Scott
Coker yeah Scott's amazing he's the one
that brought so many UFC champions from
Strikeforce right he's the one that
found all this Talent yeah I mean he
started Strike Force had got all this
talent and those Talent those talented
people became champions in the UFC
here's the question is Scott Coker too
nice to run a fight
organization is he too good of a guy
and too friendly cuz Dana's a shark yeah
you look at any like 41 500 company go
meet those guys it will hurt your
feelings how nasty they are that's why
they're there yeah Scott C you would
want to sit and have coffee with him all
day Dana I don't think
so who knows man no I know I mean no I
know no oh good question I know I've sat
with both of them I know I mean you
could tell Scott is seems like a more
dude for sure I'm telling you he's
really nice super nice yeah you know
just in order to get to that level you
got to be a bit of a s those NFL owners
go sit down with Jerry Jones let me know
ghost for you they're [__]
Savages when Steve Jobs was alive go sit
down with them Savage
dude I do think though that like if you
and Dana because you don't you don't
work together anymore if you and Dana
were just like together you guys would
get along really well I we on everything
yeah the fact that you guys work
together that's why I was kind of like
agree yeah that's that's why
like it's weird it's weird how long it
takes for the public to get over
something like even when I do my uh tour
fans come up like dude you see Dana dude
Stick it to him or I loved when he stuck
at Dana like God that was years ago Dude
really me you didn't stick it to Dana
you you were fight fighting for fighter
P I won 109 I stuck at for fighter
you're saying about the sponsorship [__]
because it affected me and it affected
everyone else that had sponsorships yeah
and now that I'm older a little more
wiser I'm like oh he wasn't making a
decision off of how can this hurt
Brendan where I took it so personal he
was like how can I make my business more
valuable talk to the top guys even
though I was a top 10 guy I was probably
top five in sponsors in in in that
division but he he would have no idea
he he's he's worried about his business
not the Bren hundreds and hundreds of
Fighters yeah dude but remember at the
time when you're fighter you're in your
own world so I took it so personal I got
so mad launched the show talked all this
[__] and I I give him kudos for that now
I'm older I'm like oh I get it I get and
now that you're running your own
business you absolutely get it yeah 100%
get it 100% get it I have no issues with
him whatsoever even on gold hour Eric uh
because uh Nick and Theo went to go do a
podcast with Dana I'm asking Nick about
it he's saw about Eric's like I thought
you guys hate him or when I was on the
fight companion um and he's like man
you're being way cooler about Dana these
days I'm like I'm 40 dude he's done
great stuff like my this entire network
is based off UFC content like I owe a
lot to that guy I have no issues with
him now zero
issues Rogan was like I liked it when
you're more of a hater like dude isn't
Dana your best one of your best friends
so am I once you wants to get a get
along people like drama people like
chaos it's sorry it's not there yeah
like er's like what the hell man I'm
like are you are you know Hot Tub Time
Machine I've been mad at the guy in
years dude we relying on everything the
moves he does
gangster gangster pelaton pulled their
sponsorship from Theo Dana was like what
pulled all B pelons yeah from or
whatever are we do the exact same thing
as as in his shoes we align on every
capacity no isues with the
guy the fighter pay thing that's
tough that's tough all right what do you
got chin all righty uh
so I showed you this uh the video
earlier about the
um the early stoppage
right um so this guy head arm choke yeah
it's weird because the the ref one of my
favorites uh it's beltron right beltron
yeah Mark or Mike beltron Mike I love
Mike we have the same tattoo artist he's
a great guy um when he reached for the
hand it's not like he was limp he was
still defending yes yeah so the the
tough part here is that Trey Ogden he
was the one that was winning basically
the entire fight so the the last two
minutes that's when the you know the
choke whatever that's when Mike belr
like stopped it and now it became a no
contest so unfortunately no contest
means you don't get your win bonus so
hopefully he's asking like dude I did
everything I was winning the fight I
should at least get my win bonus cuz
it's not his fault it's the referee's
fault for not you know yeah so hopefully
that happens that that would be so
messed up if he doesn't get his win
bonus I know yeah that's another thing
you hope Dana's watching but who knows
it's a small fight there was no energy
in that building I was watching I'm like
are we back in Co again where's the
crowd was Apex though there was eight
people
there where's the crowd I mean Apex it's
it's going to be small no matter what
though but yeah yeah
all right real quick take a little oh
it's Thanksgiving so you know what that
means great NFL gam so be thankful for
your family friends food and the NFL all
week long because you can watch and eat
turkey and get all fat and happy and
make money with draftking Sportsbook is
keeping your Thanksgiving week full of
action new customers can bet just five
buckaroos on the NFL action to score 150
instantly and bonus bets no matter your
appetite there's something for you money
lines parlays props live bets and so
much more you name it they've got you
covered you know the lions are playing
you know the Dallas Cowboys playing two
great teams so download the draftking
Sportsbook app right now use the code
shop show new customers can bet five on
the NFL Thanksgiving action to score 150
instantly in bonus bets only on
DraftKings Sports an official sports
betting part in the NFL with the code
shop show the crown is yours gambling
problem call 1 1800 Gambler and New York
call 1877 8 hope NY or text heny 467 369
in West Virginia visit w www.1 1800
gambler. net please play responsibly and
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling problem gambling call
79777 or visit ccpg dog on behalf of Bo
Casino and Resort Kansas must be 21 or
older in most eligible States but but
age varies by jurisdiction C
draftkings.com Sportsbook for details
and state specific responsible gambling
resources eligibility and deposit rest
restrictions apply bonus
expire 168 hours after issu terms at
sportsbook.com football terms dude I
feel your pain now dude is it a beast
now do that eight times a
week all right next up I'll tell you
what I couldn't get through it unless I
was on that Crow from Happy Hippo that
helps me get through the reads because
it is the best Turbo Charge for your
brain it's like a MAG Magnuson
supercharger for your brain it is
freaking crom at happy hippo you can't
just trust anybody it's the wild west
out there when it comes to the katum
game but they have it all powders
gummies Taffy energy shots you got the
KPS if you use katum this is your
OneStop shop and you get 20% off by
going to happy hippo.com promo code is
thick 23 three C's and the number two
three you get 20% off for a life for the
best katum of all time the only katum
that I trust it's the Maxon supercharger
for that brain piece it talk we talking
about happy hippo get some happy
hippo.com promo code thick
23 all righty what do you got
CH this was funny so Nina Marie love her
she's awesome crushing it she did an
interview with Tom Aspen and then Tom
Tom Aspen asked her a question here's
the thing so when you look at this yeah
you're like oh my as what the hell are
you doing but if you've watched any
anina stuff she's she's very the reason
why she's so big is she's so likable so
lovable and she's completely opposite of
what everyone's doing it's not like
she's just talking about the ex and no
of fighting and punches and kicking and
who's your next opponent are you looking
forward to it she goes outside the box
that's why she's so great she's gonna be
massive she's already big she's going to
be massive but if you cut her interviews
into little Clips you're gonna be like
what the it makes Tom seem like a
complete creep here like he should have
my mustache or Brian kins for that
matter so when you just watch this
you're like what the hell but if you
watch the entire interview it doesn't
seem as weird so you got to be very
careful she defended him too yeah she
was like cancel culture is hilarious
she's like How Are You Gonna Cancel me
in Tom so if the female interviewer
doesn't have an issue why do you if the
if the female doing the interview who's
crushing it and his friends with Tom and
all the fighters why would you have an
issue have you seen any of her Sean
Strickland coverage it's great it's like
nothing see her and Shawn are super
close so she has all this access to him
so Shawn is not like a typical strickly
interview his guard is down you can see
the real Shan Strickland that's why they
do so well here again if you take a
snippet whether it's Sean Strickland
this um giri interview she goes all
around it's different than anything
you've seen so it's G to be a little
outside the box and the fighters feel
comfortable with her that's why again
she's crushing it but again if you cut
it into Snippets of oh let's hate on
this you you can do it with any of the
interviews it's
stupid go ahead and play it um I mean
what do you think case playing the
Twitter clip yeah let's try it all right
let's give it a
shot and you can tell she's not
uncomfortable have you ever been
fingered by an MMA fighter before
fingered yeah fingered
no what would it take to you to finger
me yeah like she's off to finger me are
we talking about the same thing
but it's not like Tom would just come
out with that out of the blue it's not
like she's sitting there like so how do
you feel about John Jones or how you're
win over Sergey and he's like yeah yeah
yeah what would it take to finger you
like Jesus no no no you gotta watch the
whole interview yeah and I she said even
like uh Tom was referencing all the
comments the crazy messages she gets so
he was just kind of like playing her
role too like yeah saying the same kind
of question correct yeah it's it's all
in fun and she played like smash her
pass with Hamza it's liart it's her
thing yeah it's it's it's nothing of
this weird cancel culture Tom's creep no
but again you cut that snippet you can
do that with any show like look at this
guys make a career off doing it to me
look at the BR said this BR did this or
anybody
yeah all right so uh moving on to this
finally or not finally but thankfully uh
UFC is rebooking magamed anao versus
Johnny Walker and we mentioned that that
this will be the first fight you know in
2024 for UFC and they'll headline and
this is just them they they have to do
the rematch so that UFC is usually not
huge on rematches they have to rematch
yeah it's terrible stoppage they have to
do this to figure out who's next they
have to I would assume the winner of
this fights Alex I would imagine
too and okay so this is going to be a
few in a row so alamine Sterling said
that he was off offered Calvin cater
because he's gonna move up and wait and
then
Alaine said he's targeting Max Holloway
because he's going up in weight correct
at
45 and so the UFC is like cool say l
here's Kar and he's like well no that's
not the fight he wants someone higher
yeah a champ I don't want to fight Kar
and so now he wants to fight Max hallway
I dude takeone take my money two of the
nicest guys in the sport take my money
first team all nice and then I saw this
with Mark Rundy and interviewing Max
Holloway and uh so max Holloway says
he's shooting a shot for UFC
300 against uh Justin gatei for the BMF
belt take my money take my Goddamn money
at lightweight here's the problem for Al
Germain is Max has his eyes on this much
bigger fight against Justin gatei yeah
this is too long to read that's a UFC
300 type matchup that's that has UFC 300
all over yeah and the UFC is looking for
idea so when Max says that they go we
like that I'm sure Justin would take it
it's a great fight yeah Ma Max at 55
worries me a little bit because the
power you saw the PO a fight yeah the
the the power difference is a little
alarming there but you know his boxing
is ridiculous and if he's calling for it
then yeah I love it all right so
remember we talked about Ian garrian uh
kicked out of Leon Edwards Leon
edwards's gym because apparently some
Insider said that um like Leon was
getting or Ian was getting the best of
Leon and he didn't want that to mess
with his confidence yeah but then it
came out that Leon actually knocked
apparently he knocked him out and Leon
was like there's an interview Leon's
kind of he's on easy in the interview
because the Ian Gary stuff you know he's
just like he's just not a fit and
this in those fight camps if you put
somebody into that team and it's it
messes up the chemistry you got to get
them out and that sound sounds like it's
more of that yeah that's what you said
that's all it is is like someone's just
not a fit messes up the the chemistry
you're like yeah we he's good but we're
fine we're we're world champions without
him we're going to be fine with with or
without him he's probably better if he's
not here that's all this is yeah this
makes Ian Gary look worse I'm a huge Ian
Gary fan and he's so talented he's gonna
be Champion one day but he has to ditch
this stuff we got to ditch this drama
stuff we have to yeah so Leon did say
that his coaches and him and his team
they basically say that Ian comes in
with cameras he does all the Social
Media stuff it's like he shows up late
sometimes you know it's just back and
forth not fit yeah Ian might have to
because he's at the level he's at and he
wants to do all that stuff he might just
have to start his own team oh like VOR
BFF for did that GSP did that there's a
lot of guys Brock Lesnar did that I
don't know if he's at that level yet but
there's certain guys were like I'm just
gonna do my own thing it's about me they
just bring in certain camps where it's
not a it's team Ian Gary so you just
bring in certain pieces depend who
you're fighting but it's never the same
team it's tough dude yeah and apparently
since he's been booted out of multiple
gyms is like I don't know his
personality is so different like he's
got to's he's he's a very outlandish
dude and you know he's outspoken so it
might just rub a lot of Fighters wrong
again nothing wrong with that makes them
special I guess uh so anyways this is a
clip that they were referring to this is
last year I'm not going to play it but
it's basically his uh his I think
girlfriend at the time but now wife uh
she she said like what happened to your
mouth cuz they had to go to the dentist
cuz he got like he had it was so painful
on his mouth mouth his teeth and they
were saying that Leon Edwards did it to
him like yeah so that's kind of like
where it came from head
shot uh all right this is kind of cool
so Deontay Wilder and Eddie Hearn who've
been feuding a lot oh yeah especially
about the Joshua fight uh they somehow
were in the same place and in the same
plane and like sitting really close to
each other and now they're discussing
they're discussing a a potential matchup
finally with uh that's all this takes
man cut the [__] giv us the fights
we
want that's it that's all we got to do
Saudi Arabia announced that freaking
crazy heavyweight card which one the
only heavyweight boxing card it's like
all heavyweights Saudi Arabia
heavyweight card I think it's gonna be
Joseph Parker Deontay Wilder it's G be
Anthony Joshua's on
there tournament let's just look it up
there you go well that's May
and they announced uh Fury usk in
February yeah so thankfully it's like a
little bit
later Josh and Wilder fight separate
opponents in
December
23 any
well let me show you this real quick so
this just popped up
today it says Jake Paul is struggling to
sell boxing tickets for that venue that
just holds uh 3,000 fans so I guess as
of right now this place this takes place
in December 15th he sold half of it for
that guy that you know obviously we
don't really know the boxer yeah again
this go oh Jake can't sell Tas I look at
this go kudos to Jake yeah it's so much
easier he would have sold that out find
an MMA guy that we all know but he wants
to be taken seriously as a boxer this is
one of the downsides you're not going to
get the same traction you're not getting
the same coverage for from the MMA media
obviously so you know it's a big risk
but he wants to do it the right way so
hats off to him also 1,500 tickets sold
in 3,000 and you're still what three
weeks out four weeks out people usually
buy tickets late like last minute anyway
especially during the
holidays you know during the holidays
people they show up late so I becomes
close to sound that bad boy out it's not
terrible
no get click for sure uh so what do you
think about Jamal Hill saying that he's
going to stand up against Alex P if they
fight El for the title well Jamal's
great right he what he's wrestling no
that's not his Forte no he's he I'm
pretty sure he's well-rounded no no and
more athletic at least no all right no
yeah I mean yeah what else is he gonna
do well he's saying he's gonna KO Alex
standing up and he had he had like a ton
of like people coming at him for saying
that he would you know they're not on
his level like yri or Alex I mean
they're on this level but I mean to be
fair Jamal Hill better boxing both of
them his one too is no punk that's how
he became world champion you know that's
not an easy fight for Alex I think
that's a tougher fight for him than
Yuri because y will entertain the
grappling stuff like that Jamal no he
wants a straight
box and his hand he's fast too man in
heavy hands yeah that's a it's not an
easy fight for Alex now I think Alex
going to win the elect stuff like that
it's a great great fight I don't know
who wins that one great fight though
we're not getting it for a hot
second all right uh so I know you posted
about um David gogin training uh Tony
Ferguson but I don't think we actually
really talked about uh what you think
about this type of training right so
it's more
like well I'll say this it's more mental
so David gogin apparently put a bunch of
different athletes through his hell week
and Tony is the only one to survive it
right different level now is he going to
be overtrained maybe yeah so that's that
argument that some people are saying
like
overed for Tony I don't think there's a
a thing such as overtraining for him
he's always a guy who trains non-stop so
I think this is a perfect marriage
between him and um David gogins for Tony
I think it's more of a mental thing so
whatever happens in the fight against
Patty piml I would imagine that Tony's
down to swim further down in that Ocean
than Patty is when it comes down to it
so all this is for the the mental part
aspect of all mental well but fighting
is not just about mental fight you're
fighting a much younger guy and also
Tony has a lot of miles on them so that
Chin's not the same so even though
mentally you might be at a Jon Jones
level if your chin and your body can't
compete with that you're going to lose
the fight so like David GOI say he goes
I've done my part with him he completed
hell week mentally he's ready to go to
see the devil but it's fighting yeah you
know so I I think Tony's made the right
choice I think this is great for him
especially in the the state he's in in
his career and where he's at but at the
end of the day there's nothing we can do
to speed up his muscle memory the
reaction time the chin there's nobody in
the world can help with
that yeah he says like the fight's gonna
go the way it's going to go but yeah
yeah he's yeah David did his part I sure
as hell wouldn't go through hell week
with David Goin why uh here's a quick
one this is a pfl they're next
Pay-Per-View event uh this is the price
on it
so it's
$49.99 and this these are the headliners
here there you go that's the problem if
it was $4.99 I wouldn't I mean that's
the thing like who's going to buy the
last one a dick too I mean so Derrik
Brunson Ray Cooper that's
dope
um oam this is the problem this is the
prom chin yeah why but if you if you
don't have star pay-per-view is a star
model if you don't have stars def who in
the is going to pay for
this why are you doing this who's this
for in order for to create Stars you
have to have access to people so we can
see them and people decide if they like
them the UFC doesn't even though sugar
Shan had a great knockout win on Dan
White Contender series they don't go oh
he's on pay-per-view buy his
pay-per-view the fans like I don't know
if I like this guy sure as hell in this
economy I can pay $50 to watch him I
don't get why they're doing
it I don't either uh the last one had
800 buys or some [__] like that it was
very low for sure
terrible all right um this kind of sad
but this just happened also recently uh
so remember Julie Ki she's o OG you know
women's fighter he used to be from the
UFC she did commentating too for invict
FC she proba still does she was at
Jackson when I was there she was great
oh yeah so anyway she started feeling
symptoms of CTE like a lot of different
things that were really bad and she's um
now saying that she's going to donate
her brain to CTE research that's cool
after you know hopefully that doesn't
mean she's thinking about going or some
[__] I mean for her to make that
decision right now I think that's better
than she's at least you know I mean
she's a pioneer of the sport man if you
don't know who yeah she's oh Julia yeah
she's a
Pioneer and uh I don't I don't know if
You' seen these posts but uh chill
sunnon I knew it was fake in the very
beginning but CH suon did a post that he
got a tattoo of Anderson Silva right but
it was apparently to promote Anderson
Silva's TV series on I don't know which
what network it is but that's cool yeah
so then they watch it together and then
CH actually cried
during watching it I can't play this
clip for you but yeah I thought that was
super cool they're all best buds now
yeah I was going to ask you this this
too like so I don't know I'm I'm sure
you don't keep in touch with the people
you fought but of everyone you fought
did you ever have any like continuing
blood uh bad blood or you always like
but I never had bad blood okay I never
had any
issues yeah like the worst issue I had
was Travis Brown after the fight me him
hugged and he was like you all right I
was like I'm all right man I to jump off
imagine You' be that way I want to jump
off a bridge but I'm okay thank you sir
and you ruined my lip I look like the
guy from freaking uh Hannibal now thank
you the red dragon thank you
uh the only uh people I talked to I
fought miton of course my I remember
that one Matt's my boy uh then me and
Roy Nelson talk still that's cool
outside that it's always cool to see
like you know Rivals and then become
friends afterwards it's I never had any
Rivals probably would get paid more if I
did all
right all right let's see what's good
here there's really not oh okay let me
ask you about this
okay so the rock was on Joe Rogan's
podcast and he said that at one point he
was considering going to Pride to
fight I he wouldn't make it up what's he
need more followers I don't but I
believe it but I bet it was just thrown
out there I bet it wasn't as close let's
see 97 I was still going to La working
out we were crossing all the MMA guys
probably just open up in Japan I started
seeing all these guys going over there
probi at the time I was making 150,000
wrestling 235 days a year do the math on
that and how much you're making per
match we started hearing these guys in
Pride are making 250 up to 500,000 I
thought [__] I don't think I'm going to
make it in WWE people are booing me out
of the Arenas I can't be myself they're
telling me to [__] smile I don't want
to effing smile that's not who I am I
thought he was a smiley guy all right
started talking to Ken Shamrock I
started talking with Mark Kerr tell
about Pride I have this idea in my head
maybe I should train in MMA go to Pride
and make a real money and and I don't
have to smile I'm going to get effed up
knocked knocked one one of my lungs
loose but if I find the right coach and
train I have this whole thing in my head
talk to my wife at the time I think this
is the way to go I can make real money
while fans are booing me for
150,000 I bet there's something to that
I I bet he flowed the idea but I don't
think Pride ever made him an offer I bet
it wasn't even close to
happening yeah especially back then it
it wasn't like you're in jumpo you know
the bad boys in Pride you know what the
[__] they would have done to Dwayne
that's why when Johnson when I see this
that's I'm like really ignorance is
blissed though he's like you're making
how much money I'm a big dude if I get
some
training you
know thank God he didn't he made the
right choice becom the most famous
Meathead on the planet you know yeah
yeah I bet there's something to that but
I I I guarantee you he never started
training in MMA his coach his team never
talked to anybody at Pride but he
probably was like you're making how much
and he probably considered it but then
you know reality hits hits in but I mean
to consider at fed or and crocop and
Rampage that's what I'm saying Shogun
and Mark Kerr and Coleman
Brandman you look at these Savages
marun
over like oh it was so scary yeah oh God
no testing either my
God yep kicks of the face and [__] what
I remember the first time I saw vandelay
in Pride and I thought he was like the
scariest monster looking dude ever yeah
ever all right here's a quick one yeah I
don't think Rock's Lying by the way no
I'm not saying but to really he had the
idea but I probably never went further
than that okay so there's no way to
really know this figure but uh Tyson
Fury said that he made uh 62 million
basically 50 something Euros but that
equals 62 million USD again the says we
never know yeah there's no way to prove
this but I imagine they made a lot of
money yeah obviously a lot of money and
then and this is the last one Mike Tyson
even though he was training Francis he's
saying that Tyson Fury is going to be
the one that wins the usyk fight so is
the winner of Fury usyk the number one
Contender to fight
Francis think about it that's so F I
mean it's funny but I
mean don't in France rank number 10 now
I know my only thing is
is because the pay-per-view didn't do
the numbers they wanted is it gonna draw
the likes of another Tyson Fury usyk or
Anthony joshu or Wilder out of their
boxing Lane to fight a Francis you know
because it but again Saudis don't care
about those numbers so if your biggest
payday is fighting a go like Francis
they're probably gonna do
it would you be more excited for usyk
versus Francis or Fury rematch Fury
rematch yeah me
too yeah dude that's pretty Fury Fury
and uh Francis two can happen it's kind
of
like um Connor Nate four you can always
do that or three you can always that's
never no matter how many times they lose
what's going on you can always throw
that fight in you can know Fury could
lose to usyk fight Joshua lose to Joshua
and there's always gonna be the Francis
fight always always always Saudis know
that the numbers don't make sense to me
because that it was such a huge event
it's the timing it's the timing people
thought France would get murdered they
thought it was a circus
the the rematch I get more views but
still don't do Blockbuster
numbers I mean they probably fight three
times I assume in the rematch Fury beats
them and Fran like well I beat you the
first time there's the third one so
there's a ton of money to be made which
is all we want for Francis of course is
that right chin that's it that's it
great grand uh tour notes I'm in Chicago
next State Chicago December 8th and 99th
Chicago two shows Friday two shows
Saturday at 7 9:30 both nights Friday
Saturday Chicago two nights only
Nashville January 25th for the keepon
truck and tour kicks off in Nashville
January 25th one night only that in
Austin on Friday and Saturday one show
Friday one show Saturday one show in
Nashville so get your tickets and we got
Edmonton Fort Worth on there there's a
bunch of other dates get you some
Vancouver's on there in March get you
some at thick boy.com we got merch
dropping for Black Friday but I think we
drop it early but there's a big sale
going on at thick boy jerseys hoodies we
got the new Rockies theme uh jerseys and
hoodies and hats so you'll see it on
there I'll be post on my social media
get you some that's thick boy.com get
your tickets for Chicago at thick
boy.com as well January I'm sorry
December 8th and 9th thick boy.com all
right kids love you if you haven't
peeped yet check out Toontown uh my TRX
the first episode it's a fun one love
you guys I'm get back to figuring out
this broken lightning all right love you
be safe have a great Thanksgiving thank
you for tuning in thank you for
subscribing thank you for everything
this year um it's not the last one so I
don't know why I'm acting like that but
love you guys thank you I'm
out